sur Twitter devient payant enfin presque
aussitôt arrivé aussitôt Elon Musk vient
changer les choses si vous avez un
compte certifié un compte bleu pour le
conserver il va falloir payer en fait
c'est un abonnement Twitter Blue qui est
payé par les entreprises à 4 dollars 99
par mois qui va passer 19 dollars 99 par
mois et qui permettra d'avoir notamment
son compte certifié la petite pastille
bleue vous savez qu'on voit à côté de
votre identifiant pour assurer que c'est
bien vous que vous êtes bien certifié
alors il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
journalistes beaucoup d'entreprises
beaucoup de monde qui ont cette petite
certification qui permet d'assurer que
son bien eux derrière l'écran que c'est
pas un compte usurpé sauf que
aujourd'hui pour prouver qu'on a pas un
compte usurpé que c'est bien vous que
c'est pas quelqu'un d'autre il va
falloir payer 19 dollars 99 par mois ça
me paraît assez déconnant c'est parce
que vous en pensez dites le moi
d'ailleurs dans les commentaires le
modèle économique de Twitter jusqu'à
aujourd'hui est basé quasiment
exclusivement sur la publicité Elon Musk
compte bien sûr des abonnements payants
pour augmenter le chiffre d'affaires de
l'entreprise est-ce que vous seriez prêt
vous à payer 19 dollars 99 par mois pour
certifier votre compte et assurer que
c'est bien vous qui êtes derrière
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires